Welcome back.
In the last video, I was
confusing you with compound
interest, and now I
will continue to do so.
But the general notion is I
threw out this 100% interest
rate, and that was if we just
say you pay me 100% of what
you borrow after a year.
And then we talked about what
happens if instead you want
half the rate for six months,
but then I will compound the
interest over the
next six months.
Then we said what happens if
it's for every month or every
day, and this was the
case for every day.
And if I charged you 2.7% every
day, but I compound it for 365
days, it becomes-- I'm
just using Excel here.
Let me clear all of this.
It becomes 1.027 to
the 365th power.
Oh, I'm using my
Excel incorrectly.
Oh, that's not right.
Let's see, plus 1.027
to the 365th-- no, I'm
making a mistake here.
Let me make sure I got
this 1.027 right.
So if I takes 100% and I divide
it by 365, so 100% is the same
thing as 1 divided by 365,
that is-- oh, it's 0.00.
Sorry.
So I'm not going to
charge you 2% a day.
Yeah, that seems high.
I'm going to charge you
1.-- that is 0.00274.
I'm charging you 0.2%, right?
This would be-- this is the
kind of one percentage
place, so this is 0.2%.
So I'm charging you
0.274% per day.
I don't know why I put
brackets around that.
So if I were to compound that
over 365 days, you take it
to the 365th power, and
what does that get me?
Let's see, if I do plus
1.00274 to the 365th
power, I get 2.7148.
It equals 2-- that's how much
you're going to owe me.
If you just keep the money, you
keep kind of reborrowing it
every day, you'll owe me
$2.7148 after the
end of one year.
Now, let's say that's not
enough for you because this
interest rate is so high,
you want the option to
pay it by the hour.
You want this thing to compound
every hour of the day.
So let's see.
Let's first of all figure
out how many hours
there are in a year.
So let's see.
In a year, there's 365 days
times 24 hours per day, so
there's 8,760 hours in a year.
And then if we want to divide
100%, which is just 1, divided
by that number, I could charge
you 0.01-- what is that number?
Yeah, it's 0.0114.
So hourly compounding-- I
should've been doing this
in green since it's money.
Hourly compounding, I will
charge you 100% divided by the
number of hours in a year,
which equals 0.0114% per hour.
So over a year, I would take
it to this power, right?
So let's say after one hour,
you'll owe me 1.01-- sorry,
it's 01% so it's 1.000114.
That's how much you're going
to owe me after one hour.
So $1 plus a very small
fraction of a cent.
But then after another
hour, you're going to owe
that times that again.
Because this'll be the new
principal after an hour,
so then you're going to
owe that same fraction
times it again, right?
Then after three hours,
you'll multiply it again.
So after the total number of
hours in the year, which is
1.000114, and there's 8,760
hours in a year, let's
see what you'll owe me.
So if I do plus 1.000114 to
the 8,760th power: 2.71443.
So now, at the end of the year
after compounding roughly 8,700
hours, you'll owe me $2.71 and
then some fractions of a penny.
And I know you thought that
these videos were about e and
you were just learning about
how to take advantage of
someone in need, but there
should be something interesting
here that maybe you observed.
When we started compounding, at
first you owed me $2, just when
I did one period, which
is the whole year.
Then it got to $2.25, and then
it kept getting higher as we
compounded shorter and shorter
periods, but it seems to be
approaching some number.
It seems to be
approaching, right?
When I compounded every day, at
the end of the year, you owed
me $2.71 and some change.
And then if I compounded every
hour, which is 24 times as
many compounds, you still owe
me a very similar number.
So it seems like it's
gravitating towards this
mystical number here, and
that mystical number is e.
So let's kind of formalize what
I've been meandering around
for a video and a half now.
And I'll switch colors.
So, in general, the amount
of money you owed me at the
end of the year was the
amount you borrowed.
Let me do that in blue.
Let's call that the principal.
That's not bright enough.
The principal times 1 plus--
and what was the interest rate?
It was 100%.
100% divided by the number
of times you wanted to
compound in the year.
We'll call that n, right?
And we raise that
to the n power.
So in the case of when there's
only one compounding period,
where you just borrowed it for
the year, and the principal
in our example was 1, right?
So this is just 1 times-- the
principal is just what you
borrowed-- 1 plus-- 100% is the
same thing as 1, right, or
1.00, and when there was one
compounding period, we just did
that, and you owed me $2
at the end of the year.
And this is exactly what
I've done in the last
video and a half.
I'm just formalizing it with
a couple of variables.
When we compounded it every
month, it turned into this: the
principal you borrowed was 1
times 1 plus 100% over 12 to
the 12th power, which
equaled-- let's see.
I erased the numbers
so I will redo it.
So it's 1 plus 1 divided by 12
equals 1 plus-- I'm using Excel
for those of you who have never
seen it before-- 12
to the 12th power.
That equaled 2.613.
And when I compounded every
day, I got-- the principal you
borrowed was that times 1 plus
1 over 365 to the 365th power,
and that equaled 2.71 and
then some, some, something.
So as you see, as I make n
larger and larger in this
original equation, I approach
this magical number.
I approach this magical number
2.71 something, something,
something, and that
magical number is e.
And it amazes me that this--
and it never repeats.
It's one of these
transcendental numbers like pi,
and later on in future videos,
we'll see that it shows up
all over the place.
It shows up in random
combinatorics, it shows up in
complex analysis, and as we
see here, and maybe most
importantly, it shows up
in compound interest.
So, in general, what we
could say is the limit.
And the limit is just
what happens as you
approach something.
The limit as n
approaches infinity.
And in our example, that's as
we compound over smaller and
smaller periods of time of 1
plus 1 over n to the nth power
is equal to this magical
number, and I'll do it in a
bold color-- well, that's not
that bold, but I'll highlight
with another bold color-- is e.
And that is equal to 2.71.
I forget all the digits.
It keeps going on.
And it's really fun
to experiment.
Put in a crazy, huge-- put
in like a million there.
And if you put it there,
you have to put a
million there, too.
And you'll see that the larger
numbers you get, you just
get closer and closer and
closer to this number e.
And a fun project would be
to see how many digits
of e you can get.
But the fact that as you
compound something over smaller
and smaller periods it
converges to this number, to
me is pretty interesting.
So with that out of the way, in
the next video I'll show you
how to figure-- and so, in
the limit, as n approaches
infinity, what are you doing?
You're actually
compounding continuously.
You're compounding every
zillionth of a second.
And the fact that you can
actually calculate an interest
rate compounding every
zillionth of a second to me is
a fairly amazing result.
But anyway, I'll see you
in the next video because
I've run out of time.